you know i somehow became the go-to guy
for applying behavioral economics and
psychological principles in products and
marketing campaigns
but i've never studied either of these
fields
[Music]
tom orback thank you so much for joining
me on 20 minute leaders i'm honored to
have you here
hi i'm excited this is going to be so
much fun i'm already
said that we we're not going to have so
much time to talk about everything that
i want to talk about so i'm already
inviting you for a follow-up episode
in the future because your your field
although it's behavioral economics which
i love i got to spend some time with
dana really
at irrational labs and i just love love
love the field
and i love the message that you're going
to bring from this field
but you really are you know and have a
non-linear career pathway
all the way from an mba in cyber
security to being a lawyer
to creating professional networks of
behavioral economists and and what
you've done recently within jolt
for nude nikkei i have to say that i've
shown it to maybe a hundred people
so so i'm probably the big sharer of
this thing
because it's just uh i think it's it's
nothing less of a genius move so
tom before we continue just tell me a
little bit about yourself and
how do you find yourself through all
these different endeavors
end up in behavioral economics so you
know i somehow became the go-to guy for
applying behavioral economics and
psychological principles in products and
marketing campaigns
but i've never studied either of these
fields i'm actually i studied law i'm a
lawyer
so what happened was during law school i
went on and joined the marketing team of
two startups
and i've been a startup
in startups and the marketing man for
four years
and then i had to do the internship and
go and become a lawyer
so i i did that i ditched all of my uh
all of my experience in marketing and
went on to become a lawyer and
i remember that like in the first week
of being a lawyer
i realized that it's not where my heart
is
i mean i really enjoyed marketing i
really enjoyed the even
some product management that i did and
that's that's what i really like to do
so while doing
these these jobs
um i actually practiced a lot of
behavioral economics
i did a lot of campaigns um that apply
these principles
and i learned it by doing and then
when i was a lawyer i said that okay if
i did so so far if
if i done so far if i am i studied four
years
and then i did the internship so at
least let let's try let's be a lawyer
for
at least some time so what i did
um during uh being a lawyer i
studied every free minute i had in the
evenings
on weekends i studied and i learned and
i researched and
i did all of that in the in the field of
behavioral economics
and then i went on and did an mba in
cyber security
i don't know why yeah
it just felt right um and uh
yeah after i finished that i i said okay
um
enough is enough now let's go back to
marketing so before i did that
actually while i was a lawyer i
established a community
for a product managers and marketing
managers and
that way i could build my network and
meet
a lot of people in the industry
executives mainly
and the community is exactly about
behavioral economics because
i studied a lot and i had a lot of
insights that i felt i need to share
with the world
so i did it within the community and
that way people got to know me and that
way um
i got into jolt into marketing because
the ceo of jolt actually
saw one of my guides one of my video
guides and contacted me and invited me
to work
with jolt and that's why i'm here
sounds like a true marketer no roy
deutsches is a
fantastic great friend and adav is also
a great friend and and i think in
general
besides what you do specifically but
jolt is an incredible company and i just
love the way that you approach problems
you approach ideas and help
people on their professional career path
but tom before we even talk about
behavioral economics and psychology and
what you do or don't need to know
tell me about newt nick because that's
how i got to know you
and i i just had a huge smile on my face
as i was going through the process
tell me how that came about how did you
execute on it what did you hope to gain
and what ended up actually happening so
fun fact that
no one else knows i mean only you are
going to know it and
all of our views the reason i
established nudnik
was to try some things about behavioral
economics
i i read a few yeah i read a few
insights and
researched and i wanted to see what
happens if i apply and
if people comply uh so i said okay i
will i will create a fake website
i will declare myself as a fake ceo of
this uh
of this company and of this fake company
and then i'm going to see with analytics
exactly where people go
inside the website uh what do they do
with heat maps and you know everything
else
so people went with the flow exactly
just like i wanted
i mean there's a customer journey that i
expected the
uh within the website and it was like
straightforward
with analytics like tens almost a one
100 000 unique visitors to the website
wow and it was great so so basically
sorry i didn't explain what nude nick is
nudeniq is a actually it's a stunt it's
just a way to promote recruit
recruitment for jolt
um so it's a fake way you know it took
me a whole
customer journey to discover that but
but but really
that you go to the website immediately
you see an alarm clock right and it's a
solution that all of us
really wish we had yeah so the problem
is that people
hate waking up in the mornings because
uh because they don't have the right
reason to do it
so before the right reason i tell people
okay well use nude nick because nunic
is a an advanced ai that can wake you up
without an alarm so people
yeah let's join this and then they see
that actually
to wake up without an alarm or with a
smile on their face they can actually
join jolt
and work for a jolt which is a great
place to work at
i love that so you so you build the
customer journey you have some all those
behavioral economics insights
you build new nick are you surprised at
all by the virality that it took i mean
getting to 100 000 unique visitors
almost every startup wishes they had
that ability and you pretty much managed
to do it
seamlessly so were you surprised by the
results of that
um not really surprised because you know
that's the job of a growth marketing
manager
to to to engineer growth and organic
views and
awareness to the brand and other metrics
without a budget or
with a really small budget so that kind
of campaigns are just part of the
daily job right wonderful and so
tell me a little bit more about what
what is the job of the growth
marketer and i want to then weave that
into
the idea of psychology and understanding
your users because you also have a
really
a really nice message behind that but
first i have to understand what
is growth what is organic growth versus
you know paid growth and then how does
that go into psychology
yeah so the the easiest way
but the the most expensive way to grow a
company is by paying
to to facebook and google to promote ads
you know
that's the classic way of doing things
today in 2021
um but there's an alternative way which
is trying to find out
um ways to pull audience um
organically without a without a budget
or with a really small budget
without paying for the advertisement let
the people advertise
themselves so actually i think that
for most people in these roles the
number one
cognitive bias at play here is
reciprocity
because people in growth marketing
really uh
try to produce content marketing and
to to ac to do great stuff that come
from the company and
when when people see these great these
great
articles and blog posts and videos they
just want to
pay the company back and become
customers
so reciprocity and content marketing are
tied together
and it's it's actually one of the main
the key
the key uh things you do
in growth marketing so you really are
like an artist right i mean you sit
there and you're literally creating
these ideas that are that are
innovative by nature because things that
have proven to have
i'm assuming by the way that things that
have proven to work
on you know one day then the next day
somebody will find a way to monetize it
and make it an
a just a paid marketing idea right yeah
exactly
we can actually try to predict what will
work and what not but uh
mostly you have to do something that had
never done before and that's
that's the true magic um
wake up what a jolt you sit down in the
morning what do you actually
how do you go through that process
because you have like an empty canvas
and you have to go and innovate on on a
daily basis to
to to achieve that you know new idea
that nobody else has thought of
exactly and i think the number one
mistake that growth marketers
can do is putting all of their eggs in
one basket
i mean you should try as many
initiatives as possible
and only one will work naturally but
that's what you should do i see i i have
friends who who sit for two months and
try to plan
things and make a strategy and all for
one campaign but
maybe it won't work i don't know i mean
try just try stuff
do it just do it that's the number one
tip i have for uh
growth marketers another great example
of this is what you did with with a gif
right with jolt that took off more than
a million views i don't know how many it
has now but
a while back when i sat on linkedin
almost to two million now yeah
in court in like three weeks yeah
but really what you what you also
mentioned i believe in the blog post
that you wrote was
that you know it seems incredible 2
million but really you had another 11 or
12 gifts that you created at the same
time
that didn't have anything right so it's
not just about you know this one success
it's about
that long tale of failures but they're
all experiments that you really don't
know which one will take off
but you're learning from each one i'm
guessing right exactly and it's true for
life as well i mean just
just try stuff try as many stuff as
possible even if you don't know what to
do in your life
i mean you want to study law you want to
do
psychology behavior economics do both
try and then you'll find whatever
you think works best for you
um actually with the gifts funny story
um what i did
was uh publishing the same gift uh
from multiple accounts all related for
jolt yeah
why because gif is a very uh is
is a very noisy product you know when
you search for gifs you see all of these
animations and things moving and you can
choose the right one because
too much noise but when you see the same
gif
all around the places like um like a
repeated then you see um
it catches your attention because you
see only one gif that really
can you can focus on uh and then you
choose one of the
appearances of this gif so i think it
actually helped with the
gaining views right so talk to me a
little bit about the skill sets that are
needed that you bring to the table
because
you didn't study psychology you didn't
do a phd in behavioral economics i know
that now stanford for example offers a
phd in behavioral economics
and yet you're a growth market or an
excellent one of that you achieve
fantastic results
yet you're a lawyer you ha you have a
cyber security masters
so what skill sets do you need to to do
the job that you do do you need to study
psychology or behavioral economics
well there's a huge misconception that
only those who went and studied
psychology can talk about behavioral
economics and apply to their daily jobs
and it's not true everyone can do it and
you just need to try and experiment and
read
insights and and learn and try it
yourself and then
you see what works best because even if
in behavioral economics when you try
something
it really it's it's true only for the
experiment itself you know
you can't take it the principle and say
okay 100
it's going to work for me never you know
so you do a b tests and you do
other other experiments and you see what
works best for you so
i think that the major skill set is uh
versatility
and the ability to not become like
emotional with what you create you know
because many people
are like working on on something for a
week and then they really
hope that it is going to succeed and it
doesn't succeed and they're bummed out
but
people just need to let go and move on
to the next project
and try more stuff i think one of the
things that
first of all it takes it takes a
personality to do what you do right it
takes this resilience that grit
that entrepreneurial mindset where we're
agile it's not a waterfall you know
pipeline where you're working on a
on a marketing product for months and
then release it and hope that it garners
those millions of views
you wake up have an idea try something
and then eventually something will stick
and it will shine and and that's really
what you remember you don't remember
that
long tail of failures remember that that
those innovative notions
what's happening in the world are we
where are we moving in terms of you know
marketing growth marketing i would
really love to know because
things are changing so rapidly how are
we
starting to acquire people users to our
products so first of all and it's a
really good question that i can relate
again to behavioral economics
people hate feeling manipulated they
don't want
that they don't want to feel like you've
done something that
makes them do something that they don't
want to do
so i think that um it's actually
one of the one of the key insights that
many companies are now putting less and
less budgets on paid ads
because all of these advertisements are
basically this kind of manipulation they
try to pull you into the call to action
they try to pull you
into the website and and and that's why
we see the rise of content marketing
and other initiatives that just do good
to the world they have value
by themselves and they can attract
visitors and
then and that's the bonus okay so i
think that's the main
key insight to be good do good stuff
yeah i love that um what you're a
passionate guy i can say
you're hugely energetic you're you're
charisma because we only have 20 minutes
you know it's a sprint it's not a
marathon
you know i i did more than 300 of these
and i just get inspired by people like
you that
just exude this this this charisma and
this enthusiasm
what what are you really passionate
about what really wakes you up in the
morning without that alarm clock
what gets you going wow that's a hard
question
um so we have to make it count whoa whoa
okay
um the thing that really
i don't know making an impact you know
i'm still young i'm
20 25 years old i think
in five years i can answer that question
when i'm 30 i promise
i'll send you the right answer right now
what wakes me up is just
learning new stuff rolling with it you
know getting new insights
teaching my friends actually teaching my
network i i feel it's like it's actually
working i mean
people like what i do and what i say so
that's what
your network you've actually created
this free course no upselling
and to help other people along their
path so tell me a little bit about this
course that you've created and what's
been happening with that
yeah so it they were i took
two weeks off my job and uh i just
created a course during these two weeks
and i barely slept
i live here in tel aviv with my
girlfriend and she hated me
in that uh period mainly because i told
her from the beginning i'm not going to
sell this course i'm doing it for free
and she's like what i you're like you're
crazy why are you doing this to yourself
to yourself so i think um
i don't i don't know why i did that i
mean it was fruitful i mean i do see
with reciprocity how many people
um come to me and consult with me and
offer me jobs like read deutsch and um i
i think it's working do good stuff
contribute to the world and teach the
world
show what you can do and the world will
give you back
i love this outlook so i'm gonna try to
extract a few more nuggets from you
while i do have you here
looking at you know a wealth of consumer
products and and
brands and this whole notion of of
reciprocity and trust that you're
building what are some
what are some things that as a young
entrepreneur and other young
entrepreneurs what should we keep in
mind
as we go on to build our next products
from the get go because i think
and correct me if i'm wrong but i think
that what you're talking about is a
bigger
cultural idea that when we build things
we we should strive to have do them with
reciprocity with trust
with their an honest and authentic
connection to the users
and not just try to buy our way into
them so what are some things to keep in
mind
for a young entrepreneur so i think that
when you build a product
you should first think about when the
customer will
stop using the product you should
provide exit points
you should tell the user okay i don't
want to get you hooked i don't want to
to i don't want you to sit for two hours
using the
the app or the product uh you should
decide for the user or at least
suggest the user now it's your time to
stop
uh so providing ex even ticktock does
that actually
when you scroll for like yeah if you
when you scroll for
too long there's a pop-up message and in
window pop-up and such that tells you
maybe it's time for to stop for today
and
it's actually good not not by um
not only for the health of the customers
but also for a sense of completion
people love finishing stuff yeah
so when they when they see okay now it's
time to stop and even the app suggested
it
they're happy in any way um so i think
i think that when you build a product
the first the first step is actually to
think
uh when is the customer going to stop
using the product
and build that at first and i actually i
have a probably i
get a good guess that most people they
see that pop up
they continue to scroll nevertheless
because who are they to tell me to stop
but they still have that completion
feeling and
they have the trust that they say okay
wow i love tic tok even more
and therefore i'm actually going to
continue scrolling so it's a win-win
situation for everybody
i think so too you know the peak end
rule
what is that it's a very basic rule that
says that when you experience something
you will remember the peak and the end
of that experience
so either way when you continue using
tick tock after that pop-up message
that's a peek
you were so happy that the update cares
of you
and it was a the pop-up was probably
during uh
or after a very good tick tock you've
seen so that's a pick
and it could have been an end also a
happy end because you're happy that the
uptick
take care of you so yeah i love that tom
i want to thank you for being so
generous with your time thank you for
for joining me here i know how busy you
are
and i can't wait to continue following
your journey and seeing the incredible
innovations that you bring and and i'm
growing to love growth marketing more
and more because it's just
it's such an innovative field that is
just inspiring for me to see to see all
these different
initiatives that you have so thank you
for that before we leave i have to ask
you for the most important
and fun question which is three words
that you would use to describe yourself
um energetic fast moving
and a generalist i'm not trying to be an
expert in any one fields
anyone feel they want to be as much
in much fields as possible tom thank you
very much
and stay safe and stay healthy